Chris waters here with a gamespot news  update today Assassin's Creed unity was  confirmed for the Xbox one the  playstation 4 and the pc earlier this  week several in development images of  Assassin's Creed unity were leaked  showing off the game setting in 18th  century France a video was then posted  to Ubisoft youtube channel that  officially revealed Assassin's Creed  unity and the developers said that the  game had been in the works for more than  three years for next-gen systems the  xbox one the playstation 4 and the pc  with the wii u being conspicuously  absent a separate Assassin's Creed game  for xbox 360 and playstation 3 is also  reportedly in the works the game is set  to release some time this holiday season  and of course we'll have all the latest  Assassin's Creed news right here on  gamespot com